[Music]
Netflix gives us a first look at squid
Game season 2 and the drama surrounding
Spider-Man 4 continues Sony and Marvel
cannot agree on how to proceed meanwhile
the next star leaves Marvel's
Thunderbolts and director Deni venev
makes an announcement about the
conclusion of his dun Saga all this and
much more now in the Koch
news action fans listen up a feature
film adaptation of the cult series Kung
Fu is coming with none other than Donnie
Yen in the lead the popular martial arts
actor is known for movies such as itman
and John Wick chapter 4 and will be
taking on the lead role in the project
according to deadline the original TV
series which was released in 1972 tells
the story of a Shaolin monk who wanders
through the Wild West in search of his
brother and has all kinds of Adventures
originally the role of Cain was to go to
the legendary Bruce Lee who also came up
with the IDE idea for the series but it
was ultimately given to David kerine the
Kung Fu franchise has returned time and
time again over the years for example as
the police drama Kung Fu The Legend
Continues in the 9s the current feature
film adaptation will be directed by
Bullet Train director David Leech Steven
Chin pen the screenplay while fans are
eagerly awaiting further details about
the Remake initial information indicates
that the reinterpretation will be a
genuine tribute to the old series it
remains to be seen how the combination
of the old story with a contemporary
staging will turn out with Don yen in
the leading role there will surely be a
lot to look forward to at least in terms
of martial
arts a strong support for Clark Kent
House of the Dragon Star Millie Alcock
will be the new supergirl in James gun's
DCU the decision was recently revealed
by the superman Legacy director himself
via Instagram after an intensive
selection process Alcock prevailed over
well-known competitors such as Amelia
Jones and Meg Donnelly the role of
Superman's cousin has so far been played
by Melissa Benoist in six seasons of the
series of the same name as well as in
other DC Productions in the DC EU
Blockbuster The Flash Sasha Kay was able
to make a strong impression in the role
fans considered Kaye to be a very
promising cast member but DC opted to
cast the role from scratch instead
according to James gun the character
will be given a completely new look and
will be very different from her cousin
Superman Hara zor's backstory is
described as being more hardcore as she
had to witness her entire surroundings
being wiped out in her early years
Superman on the other hand was raised by
loving parents on Earth the woman of
Steel will get her own movie in the DCU
with Supergirl woman of tomorrow but we
firmly assume that she will already make
her debut as part of a smaller
appearance in Superman Legacy on July
11th
2025 it's not an easy time for all
Spidey fans after the huge success of no
way home part four seemed to be going
well however a clash of interests
between Sony and Marvel regarding the
future of the spider could now lead to
some issues with impressive box office
takings of over $ 1.9 billion US
Spider-Man no way home not only made the
cash tills ring but it also raised
expectations for a potential fourth
installment in the franchise despite
works on Spider-Man 4 currently being on
hold rumors have been circulating for
months as comic book movie reports s
with reference to Reliable Insider
Daniel Rickman Spider-Man 4 is facing an
interesting dilemma apparently there are
two fundamentally different Visions as
to how the fourth adventure of the
friendly spider should be created the
funding Studios Sony Pictures and Marvel
Studios which have already worked
together on the previous movies are
faced with a challenging creative
process on the one side Sony is aiming
for another Blockbuster in the style of
no way home or more precisely another
big reunion of many well-known Marvel
characters
thanks to the Multiverse the last film
already featured previous Spider-Man
actors Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
Who provided plenty of support Sony
seems to find this idea of an epic
reunion extremely appealing on the other
side Marvel boss Kevin feige is
advocating for a more grounded approach
in Spider-Man 4 instead the plot should
focus more on the personal and emotional
aspects of Peter Parker that would make
perfect sense after all Peter was erased
from everyone's memory by the events in
no way Hall
the different approaches of the studios
point to another dispute over the future
of Spider-Man in the MCU as was the case
with the predecessor back then actor Tom
Holland had to pick up the phone
personally to talk to Disney boss Bob
Iger about the subject it seems that
spidey's future is once again on Shaky
Ground fans can only hope that the
creative minds behind the scenes will be
able to find another solution that takes
into account both Sony's demands and
Marvel's Vision part four is still a
long way off anyway a theatrical release
before 2026 is currently
unlikely in 2021 squid game was a
genuine surprise success on Netflix and
fans are eagerly awaiting the second
season Netflix is now finally providing
us with a first look at what awaits Us
in the sequel here's some happy news
squid game 2 is coming in
2024 this was announced on Thursday at
the next on Netflix event along with a
short clip in it main character guun
receives a strange phone call telling
him that he will regret his decision
however he will not be dis awaited from
his Vendetta in Squid Game season 2 we
can also expect to see other familiar
faces such as the frontman and the
salesman from season 1 the Korean series
is about a brutal competition in which a
large number of participants have to
play children's games to win huge prize
money with a fatal outcome for all
losers the Netflix hit also led to the
reality version squid game The Challenge
which made headlines with numerous
injuries to the participants sadly the
exact release date of squid Game season
2 is not yet known but we will keep you
up to date as
always the end is near in an interview
director Deni venev revealed that he
could well imagine a third part of the
Dune Saga however this would be the last
movie he directs based on the universe
the original idea was to adapt the
famous novel by Frank Herbert into two
movies thanks to the worldwide success
of Dune the director was able to
implement his plan Dune part two which
villan neev describes as an
action-packed in Epic War film is
finally due to be released at the end of
February after a number of delays of
course fans of the original know that
the movie is merely an adaptation of the
first novel Dune however the literary
work about oracus includes several other
books that also provide material for
potential movie adaptations in an
interview with Tha magazine banev stated
that he would definitely be interested
in directing another movie after June 2
part three is to be based on Frank
Herbert's second novel Dune Messiah
despite the lack of official approval
from Warner Brothers banev has already
made it clear that this would probably
be his last project in the Dune Universe
the director also revealed that work on
Dune 3 was already in full swing he
added that the script for the movie was
already as good as finished lead actress
zandia who plays the role of chanie in
Bev's Dune movies also expressed her
enthusiasm for a possible third movie in
an interview with Fandango she explained
that she would definitely be involved if
Den vev were to call her again Timothy
sham AKA Paul a trades likewise voiced
his enthusiasm regarding the idea of
another movie he emphasized that the
entire cast was very much hoping to
complete the story with Dune Messiah
should the opportunity arise however
despite these positive statements it
could still be a while before the third
movie becomes a reality banev has spent
the past 6 years making the first two
Dune movies and is considering taking a
break before directing the third
installment he hinted that that he might
tackle another project first in order to
recharge his batteries and find
inspiration so it remains to be seen if
and when Dune 3 will actually be
released but this much can already be
said it is unlikely to fail on account
of the fans excitement as it currently
seems
undiminished one star follows the next
after Steven Yun left the production of
the action hit Thunderbolts Rising Star
AO adury will now also no longer be part
of the project as reported by deadline
ad diber is leaving the production due
to scheduling issues the 28-year-old
actress first attracted attention in
2020 with Cooper Ra's Coming of Age
comedy drama Shi house and went on to
become one of Hollywood's most
sought-after young actresses in The
Following years in 2023 she then won an
Emmy for her performance in the bear
although the departure of Yun and AD
debery is anything but positive for the
production of thunderbolts Marvel was
not disheartened and quickly recast the
two roles Lewis Pullman will portray the
unstable superhero Century while
Geraldine banon replaces AO adury in an
as yet unknown role this wathon has
already proved herself to be a
multifaceted actress and has made a
lasting impression in many film projects
in addition to her role in Thunderbolts
she will also be seen in the cast of
Ethan Cohen's new movie driveaway dolls
currently it can only be assumed that
the reunion of yena Bova Bucky Barnes
Red Guardian and the others will make
its way to theaters on July 25th 202 2
let's hope that everything runs smoothly
from now
on it's now been 8 years since Ben
Affleck won over critics and fans in his
role as a battle Harden accountant now a
sequel seems to be coming soon as part
two is due to go into production this
year the action thriller the accountant
was not only very popular among
audiences but also proved to be
extremely profitable with a relatively
modest budget of $44 million the movie
grossed over $15 million
worldwide although a sequel has already
been announced in 2021 the project
really seems to be gathering Pace now as
deadline reports filming is set to begin
as early as this year which makes a
release in 2025 a possibility Ben
Affleck will be back in front of the
camera as Christian wolf for part two
directed by Gavin oconor in the
cinemablend podcast OK Conor revealed
that he could even imagine a third part
which in his own words would be a
Rainman on steroids since the character
bra played by John Bernthal is set to
play a bigger role in the accountant too
the actor's return is almost certain
whether anak Kendrick will also join the
project remains to be seen in addition
to the accountant 2 Affleck will also be
working on the kidnap Thriller animals
this year which he is directing himself
in the lead role is his buddy Matt
Damon granted not every piece of news
from the Hollywood world is positive but
don't be upset there are also some true
highlights awaiting us in the near
future for example despicable mi4 take a
look at our Koch original where we give
you all the top updates on grw and the
minions and don't forget to check out
the trailer as well
[Music]
enjoy